one thing that i reflected when i saw
the video for the first time
is i thought to myself oh you know
your entire career we've been at war you
know i spent
more than half my career we weren't at
war you know we was in the 90s the dry
years but i'm thinking man this guy's
been in the marine corps for 17 years
the marine corps and america has been at
war for that entire time you as you
mentioned you said you know you got a
lot to lose
you knew what could happen you knew you
were risking your battalion command you
know family stability the whole nine
yards
you bring up that letter from the from
the commandant that he wrote
and
[Music]
you know you mentioned did anyone throw
their rank on the table and say we
shouldn't give up bagram
which again you know going back to the
the silent five which is what mcmaster
called the the joint chiefs of staff
that worked for lbj
and you can even hear you know that i've
read in the beginning of guys that
reflected back and said
i should have said something i should
have i should have stood up
um
you talk about the fact that
the people that died dying in vain if we
don't
uh
you say you said if we don't own up and
say we did not do this well in the end
and
you know i always look at that when
someone gets wounded or killed in combat
at a at a bare minimum at a bare minimum
at least we go okay we can learn from
what happened in the situation we can
pass it on we can make sure it doesn't
happen again
and
that's what you're talking about
um
and
[Music]
you kind of close it out by saying i've
been fighting for 17 years i'm willing
to throw it all away to say back to say
my two to my senior leaders i demand
accountability
and that's it
um pretty simple straightforward message
you hit post i hit post you hit post um
how long did it take before
you know you started getting texts from
your friends and your senior leadership
good question uh no one's asked me this
question yet so i walked in the house
didn't say anything
got upstairs and
i was sitting in my bedroom on the bed
my wife was getting ready for bed
she got a text
she said did you post a video
i was like yep i sure did
she's like you know i won't say that
girl's name she's like so-and-so my
friend is texting me saying you're going
valve right now and i was like oh going
what viral okay
i was like you should probably watch the
video tell my wife so she watched it and
she's like you need to take this down
this is we're going to get in trouble
take it down
and i was like babe it's already up
like you can't can't put the lid back on
the bottle and even if i could i don't
know if i'd want to
and so this is me saying this in this
moment i was like i i really believe in
what i said in that video like i feel
very strongly about it
and so my wife then started feeling the
gravity of what i had just done started
stressing out and so then i went
downstairs was sitting on the couch and
was just kind of thinking and then all
my friends started texting me one of my
friends from marsoc actually texted me
and said stu
everything you said in that video is
correct but it's going to come at way
too high of a personal cost and you're
not going to change anything he's like
take it down
and i told him i was like no this is the
hill i'm willing to die and i'm not
taking it down and then i had one of my
instructors from aitv
who texted me is gunny as a section
leader awesome dude
he's like hey sir i watch your video and
i agree with everything in your video
but
our adversaries could take this video
and use it against us and i think you
need to think about that and i think you
should take it down
and to him i said you know
there there's probably even some truth
to that but if we can't fix internally
what we're doing right now
with this conversation that i'm trying
to start then
it's all for nothing
and so i guess those are all three true
stories where i was like you know from
my loved ones from my friends from the
people that worked for me
were oh i mean i and there's like 10
other examples right so my phone blew up
that night no one none one in my chain
of command contacted me that night
so just people that knew me
and
you know i i've never
like my wife and i never like slept in
separate rooms even when we were angry
like early in my marriage i was like i'm
never you're never making me sleep on
the couch right like this is our house
we sleep together we're gonna deal with
stuff
but like that night i slept on the couch
and i bring that up just to illustrate
like that's how stressful it was it was
just like
was she mad just basically because you
were you were torpedoing your own career
yeah like i said i mean we had stability
like in those three years probably for
the first time in our life and she
thought she was going to be there i had
just taken battalion commander sees so
she knew i was going to be there for at
least another two years and i only had a
year after that until retirement so she
knew she had another three years in
north carolina she had just started a
new job as a teacher the kids were all
in the same school for the first time
she finally had all the stability that
she wanted and then this
took her by complete surprise and she
knew that i probably wouldn't even have
this job much longer so every all the
stability she thought she had i took
from her
some people asked me about
this when it was happening and i was
like on social media or something like
that and i got asked about actually no i
think i was getting interviewed on a
news channel
but
you know my response was
um
it i guess i drew subconsciously from
what hackworth says when they say oh do
you think you become emotional
and he's like yes i have become
emotional because i've watched so many
good men die
and
um
i am emotional and that's sort of what i
said i said listen here's a here's a guy
that's been
at war for 17 years who i guarantee he's
lost marines and
he's sitting here looking at this
situation saying this is i'm not like
i'm not taking this anymore
when did you hear from your chain of
command the next day
so as a battalion commander i was always
the first one in the office and it just
so happened
that that day my wife had a medical
appointment and i had agreed to drop the
kids off
at like
at school at like let's call it eight
o'clock
and so it was like an abnormal
occurrence so that's like the one day i
didn't show up early and so
um i take the kids
and so now i don't get into work until
like 8 15. and as a battalion commander
you don't tell people when you're coming
in you just
show up at a normal time but i had
texted my option xl i can't run late
and
so i tell you that just to say my co had
stopped by my office and called like
three times
um and my op so called me and was like
hey sir
co was really looking for you should
probably call them and so when i drove
in i got in i think at like 8 30 that
morning
still
was actually walking because his
building's let's say a two minute walk
from my building he was actually walking
between the buildings and i saw him and
so i stuck my head out the window i was
like do you want to you want me to come
back to your place he's like no just
meet me in your office
so by the time i went and parked my
truck and went into my office like he
was already sitting in my office waiting
for me
and what do you say
the first conversation
between colonel emil and i
i mean he he came off as actually very
caring
keep in mind this is a
career colonel command selected that
doesn't know me very well
i've never met him before my battalion
command so he's had about six weeks of
meetings maybe like
seven meetings with me
so just imagine i mean he's another
professional i'm a professional he
doesn't know me it's not like a guy i've
been working for for a couple years
or even a guy that knows a guy that i
know real well like i don't know anyone
that really knows me they're like we
just don't know each other we hadn't
developed much of a relationship
so he's like so he posted a video yes
sir and he didn't really there wasn't
much small talk he said i wish you would
have talked to me first if you would
have talked to me first we could have
worked through some of this and that's
and he's right and that's the
appropriate way
and i said yes sir i understand
and he's like i think that this video
might be used
to run messages that may not have been
your intent i wish you would have
thought of that
and again he was right
and then he just stated look
there's going to be an investigation
that's going to take place
and then based on the investigation
we're going to determine what to do
i'd like you to go home take the rest of
the day and i will text you on monday
with where we stand and like all of that
was very reasonable right very
reasonable stuff was this already like
on fox news and uh hitting the news
outlets and all that at this point
no so this was still sort of
you know
your facebook friends you know and then
like or was it
how big was it i mean i think it
probably had received
like 10 000 shares
so
i mean by the end of the night it was
picked up by all the major news stations
so in the morning like the commandant's
office knew about it i mean everyone
knew about it but you know it hadn't
been picked up by mainstream media yet
but it does by the end of the day but
like it wasn't like everybody knew
hey when your friend your gunny and your
wife were all like hey dude
take take it down
yeah what was the question
i mean they everyone knew
yeah and so my ceo left
my exo came in
and i turned over the
battalion to him and
then i went home
and then
and then when i got home
my co called me an hour later and said
hey i need you to come back in i'm sorry
to jerk you around
oh that was weird i was like all right
you meet me at my office he's like no
meet me in my office
okay
so i meet him in his office and he just
looks at me and says and hands me a
piece of paper and says you've been
relieved for cause based on a lack of
trust and confidence
do you have any questions
yes
what do i do now he's like i need you to
come in tomorrow he's like what will
probably happen is
there will be an investigation
and i don't think they're going to keep
you here he's like they'll probably move
you up to quantico
and
general alford asked to maintain the
investigation so that he can take care
of you that's what he said i was like
okay
i'm trying to trying to like reconcile
that in my mind
and but at the end of the day like i
kind of knew i'd be relieved over it and
i just said okay sir and so i signed the
piece of paper that said i had been
relieved
i walked out
and i actually made a post like
immediately after it's still up on my
pages my facebook and linkedin and just
and i was very appreciative i said
i think effective of 1400 today i've
been relieved and then my command is
doing exactly what i would have done i'd
like to thank them for the opportunity
of getting to serve as the aitb
battalion commander and i look forward
to the next chapter right so very
appreciative post
obviously something changed for your
regimental commander somebody talked to
him and said all right this is what
we're doing yeah uh and by just so
everyone just so civilians know what
you're talking about relieved a command
means you just got fired yeah so you got
fired it and battalion command is a huge
stepping stone and it's
a huge responsibility so the
ramifications were i would never get
promoted again
and
you know as you worked through it in
your mind i had been relieved so i'd
been fired so i knew i would never be
promoted again but i knew that there was
still potential for legal action
right so like best case
i
am just like a disgraced lieutenant
colonel cubicle somewhere limping
towards retirement
but you know worst case was i could be
separated out via legal action
and so i didn't know i was just unknown
at that time